my name is a fertilizer from Gothenburg
Sweden hey I'm here on from friends hi
I'm Dominic I'm from Zurich Switzerland
they are from angry i'm here from oslo
in norway my name is Elise holiday and
I'm from Austin Texas
we organized CSS convey you because we
believe in the community and we believe
that only by sharing we all can develop
it I'm organizing CSS called view
because to me it's the perfect
opportunity to give something back to
the community the quality of each talk
today has been really fantastic and I
rhian joy how passionate every single
speakers about the topic
today my talk was about localization of
content stay at t expect my emotion tzm
today I talked about having fun with
developing
I absolutely love the community behind
CSS especially CSS comp they make it
such a diverse inclusive event that it's
so wonderful to hear so many different
opinions and so many different
backgrounds remember going and I just
love coming and being all the community
from your worldwide it's it's a very
well organized conference the food is
fantastic the coffee is fantastic the
talks are really good but what I like
the most is the community spirit so I
can't wait for next year I'm so honored
to be a part of it and go CSS
you
you